43 of chad's political factions and
armed groups have signed the
long-awaited peace agreement
giving the opposition and the
transitional military council cause for
hope
it was a very tough and difficult talks
but what is important is the result
which we got at the end of this loan
process
and i think that this agreement
will
lead us to a sustainable peace in child
a ceasefire general amnesty and the
national dialogue will be the first
articles to be implemented
the dialogue due to be held later this
month in the capital in germany is meant
to lead to the formation of a government
of national unity constitutional reforms
and democratic elections
qatar which sponsored the talks says the
agreement is just the beginning
very helpful that it will end
hostilities between the different
parties it will move the process from a
military process to a political process
and will allow for an easy transition
towards the negotiations in chad itself
but not all factions have signed the
deal among the absentees in doha on
monday was one of the largest armed
groups the front for change and
conquered in chad or fact
i think at the beginning
we were
a little bit sure that
factory will not sign they were putting
some unacceptable conditions
for the government among
which there is the release of the
prisoners just after the signing
the peace agreement is still open and
then still open for everybody to join
the peace agreement in the future so we
urge and then today i urge everybody he
didn't sign and then because this is a
historic moment for the chadians
chad one of the poorest countries in the
sahel has been locked in internal
conflict for decades
fighting among armed groups has forced
hundreds of thousands of people from
their homes
when muhammad debi replaced his late
father as president last year he
promised political reform and launched
the peace talks
that led to the doha court
chad has seen dozens of similar
agreements in the past none of them held
and that's why there is some concern
about the future of this latest one but
many of the signatories tell us that
after six years of conflict many
charities say they are tired of war
and ready for peace muhammad